hello and welcome to everyone joining us
from around the globe thank you for
being part of day two of our special
series Ted connects this week we're
bringing you interviews from some of the
world's greatest minds offer tools for
us to navigate through and thrive in
these really uncertain times I'm Whitney
Pennington Rogers Ted's current affairs
curator and I'll be one of your hosts
for today's event yesterday we kicked
off this series with an interview from
acclaimed psychologist Susan David who
offered us some tips on how to really be
our best selves in these trying times
and we're gonna switch gears a little
bit today from thinking about our own
personal mental health to the state of
our global public health systems thank
you I guess we have a pretty exciting
guest to introduce on the other side of
the country
let's bring in Bill Gates bill they say
the the best known people are the less
you have to insure them so it's great to
have you here how are you doing well I
think this is a unprecedented really
disconcerting time for everyone with
things being shut down not knowing
exactly how long it's going to last
worrying about the health of all the
people we care about mm-hmm you know I'm
lucky that I get to connect up with
video conferencing using teams a lot so
that you know foundation is stepping up
and there's a lot of great people trying
to help with this crisis but it it's
scary for everyone you basically stuck
at home like like many of us watching
yeah almost all my meetings are using
teams now I'm getting used to that you
know I've gone days without seems seen
any work coworkers
let's talk here bill five years ago you
stood on the Ted stage and you gave this
this chilling warning that
the world was in danger at some point of
a major pandemic people watching that
talk now you know the hair stands up in
the back of their neck it is it is
exactly what we're living through what
happened it did people listened to that
warning at all basically no you know I
was hopeful that with the Zika and a
bola and SARS and MERS they all reminded
us that particularly in a world where
people move around so much you can get
huge devastation and so the talk was to
say hey we're not ready for the next
pandemic but in fact there's advances in
science that if we put resources against
them we can be ready sadly very little
was done there were some things the
Coalition for epidemic preparedness
innovation CEP I was funded by our
foundation Wellcome Trust and a number
of governments to do some of the
platform vaccine work but the in the
area of Diagnostics antibodies
antivirals basically doing the disease
games that I talked about where we'd
simulate what needed to be done we
hardly did anything and and so now here
we have a respiratory virus that is
sadly fulfilling some of the more
negative predictions I made I mean last
month you said that this might be the
big one you you you you wrote that this
this could be the sort of
once-in-a-century
pandemic that people had been fearing is
that how you think of it still well I
it's awful to say this but we could have
a respiratory virus whose case fatality
rate was even higher if this was
something like smallpox you know that
kills 30 percent of people so this is
horrific but you know in fact most
people even who get the Co
a disease are able to survive so in in
that it's quite infectious way more
infectious than MERS or SARS were it's
not as fatal as they were and yet the
disruption were seen in order to knock
it down is is you know really completely
unprecedented so this is a you know it's
going global that was it's respiratory
that was the great fear how many people
end up dying hopefully you know if we do
the right things it won't be a gigantic
number so it's you know we should end up
not having the 1918 flu situation we
should be able to do a lot better than
that and that's that's because of
actions that we would take I mean left
without the right actions the prospects
are pretty are pretty deadly I mean if
we if we knew what we knew in 1919 this
thing could take out many tens of
millions of people around the world
because like you said is the key thing
here that is it's got this sort of
strange combination of being certainly
more dangerous than flu not as dangerous
as something like Ebola or SARS but more
interesting than flu by a factor but but
but infectious and and also infectious
before symptoms have started is that
part of why it's it's been really hard
to respond to you
right so Ebola you're actually flat on
your back before your very infectious so
you're not at church or in a bus or at a
store with most respiratory viruses like
the flu and kovat at first you only feel
a little bit of a fever and a little bit
sick and so there's the possibility
you're going about your normal
activities and infecting other people
and so right you know human and human
transmissible respiratory viruses that
in the early
stage aren't stopping you from doing
things that's kind of a worst case and
that's where you know I did a flu
simulation in the 2015 talk and showed
how quickly it spread you know versus
1918 people move around a lot more now
than they used to and so that works
against us now the medical system that
steps up to treat people is also far far
better but it was when was it clear to
you that that unless we acted this this
could be a really deadly pandemic well
in January it was discussed that there
was human human transmission taking
place and so you know the alarm bells
were ringing that this fits the very
scary pattern that it will be very
difficult to contain and in in on
January 23rd China did their equivalent
of the shutdown did it in a fairly
extreme form the very good news is that
they were able to reduce the infection
rates dramatically because of those
actions but it's it's January where
everybody should have been on notice
let's get our act together with testing
let's get going on therapeutics and
vaccines we've got to get organized
because we have this novel respiratory
virus whose infectiousness and fatality
put it in that super scary range and so
what what did happens is such a mystery
to me about the sort of the last month
of preparation certainly I mean in many
countries and certainly in the u.s.
we're where we are were you on the phone
to people during early February late
January early February saying you know
guys you know what's going on this is a
really big deal what are we doing what
what was happening behind the scenes
during
period well you'd like to have
government money show up for the key
activities we put out a hundred million
we created the therapeutics accelerator
there's the period between when we
realized it was transmitting and now
where we should have done more I think
the most important thing to discuss
today is that in the area of testing
we're still not creating that capacity
and applying it to the people most in
need and so we have health workers who
are symptomatic who can't get a test and
so they don't know should they go in and
not go in and yet we have lots of tests
being given to people aren't symptomatic
and so the testing thing to me it it's
got to be organized it's got to be
prioritized that is super super Junt the
second thing is the isolation that you
know various parts just focusing on the
u.s. some parts are doing that in a
fairly strong way and other parts not
yet and you know it's very hard to do
it's tough on people it's disastrous for
the economy but they sooner you do it in
a in a tough way the sooner you can undo
it and go back to normal I sense it will
come to the isolation pot in in a minute
but it's just sticking with the testing
thing I'm just so confused as to why
with more than a month's notice I mean
there are so many smart epidemiologists
in the in the US for example you plug
numbers about infectious nurse and
fatality into any simulation and you see
that if you don't do anything millions
of people will die and there's a month
so what what's your explanation for what
what do you think happened here as to
why just know there was almost no test a
month later there was no viable test in
the US was this just government
complexity too many chefs in the kitchen
what on earth happened here
well we certainly didn't take advantage
of the month of February the good news
is that the actual process the PCR
machines we have a lot in the United
States and so there's models like South
Korea who took advantage of February
built up the testing capacity and they
were able to contact race and their
infections have gone down even without
the type of shutdown that because we're
late we're having to do one thing that
is good news just this week is that
people are thought to do this test that
you have to have a nurse or doctor shove
a swab way up all the way to the back of
your throat which hurts a lot but also
you're gonna cough and potentially
spread the disease to that healthcare
worker so they have to have protective
equipment and change that what we sent
data to the FDA this weekend showing
that just a individual by themselves
swabbing up to the tip of their nose
they are able the accuracy of that test
is essentially the same as having a
healthcare worker do it that helps a lot
it we still have to do other things but
that means that you don't have to change
protective equipment you just hand the
patient that swab they do it put it in
the test tube and if the capacities
right within 24 hours you should get
that result back so how do you see that
playing out that other people kind of
massively scale there's those tests and
and how will how will ordinary citizens
be able to get hold of them it does it
still have to be actually kind of
prescribed by a doctor at some point or
at some point will you be able to just
order them off Amazon or something and
well pretty chaotic today because the
government hasn't stepped in to make
sure that the testing capacity is both
increased and it's used for the right
cases there will be a website and if the
federal
doesn't do it a lot of local governments
will have to do it that you go to you
give your situation including your
symptoms you're told you know based on
your work and your symptoms are you a
priority if so you're told where there
are kiosks you can go to and you'll do
the self swab and just hand it over or
eventually we'll send the kits to you at
home and then you'll send it back and
and hear that result maybe six months
from now you'll actually be able to have
a strip where you perform the tests in
the home but for now they sending it
back for the PCR processing we can have
massive capacity there and that's how
you know the testing is everything
because that's how you know whether you
need to do more shutdown or you're
starting to get to the point where you
can relieve it some people are trying to
argue now that almost the testing should
be dogged back because you know the cat
is out of the bag testing is bringing
people together and risking infection
you know forget that let's just focus on
treatment and on isolate and on
isolation strategies you disagree with
that testing is still absolutely
essential and it needs to be swelling it
did go together our testing at very high
volume and the isolation piece if you're
a if you're a medical worker you want to
stay and do your job if you're making
sure the electricity water or food is
still available you want to do your job
and so testing is what indicates to you
do you need to go into isolation and
make sure you're not the source of
spread and so you know testing is is the
key thing you know South Korea did that
in this massive way that you know
everybody should learn from and so that
it that is paired with the isolation
piece our goal here is to get to the
point where a very small percentage of
the population is infected you know
China only 0.01 percent of the
population was in
affected if you let it if you don't do
these things you're gonna get to the
majority people infected and that huge
overload of the medical system Whitney
has some questions from our online
audience
Whitney some of the questions that we're
seeing are about how our tech giant's
and leaders can play a role in in
isolating this and containing this on
this virus you know the tech companies
are very involved in making sure that
some work can go on
you know people can stay in touch you
know they can help with some of the
disease modeling they can help with the
disability of the numbers it's actually
very impressive you know you get up
there and you can see you know those
numbers actually they're sad numbers but
you know everybody is able to monitor
this thing back in 1918 they didn't have
this type of visibility and an ability
to share best practices but for a lot of
people the isolation is the key thing I
mean bill one of the the riddles about
this isolation strategy is how long it
how long has to last right like a lot of
people are concerned that the the price
of victory by isolating everyone is that
you crash the economy and that you know
what we have to be basically at home not
doing our regular jobs for three six
months maybe it may be all year and so
much so that there's now this big debate
in the US and other countries about this
may just be the wrong strategy that we
can't crash the economy that badly we
should only isolate for another couple
weeks and then let people back and if
that means you know a lot of other
people get sick and we eventually build
up herd humidity that may be the right
the right way to go what's your thought
on this what is the isolation strategy
that eventually leads to us getting back
to normal and it's very tough to say to
people hey keep going to restaurants you
know go buy new houses ignore that pile
of bodies over in the corner just you
know we want you to keep spending
because there's some
maybe a politician who thinks GDP growth
is is what really counts it's very hard
to tell people when there's an epidemic
spreading that you know threatens
particularly their parents or elderly
people that they know that they should
go about things knowing that their
activity is spreading this disease I
don't know of any rich countries that
have chosen to use that approach it is
true if you did that approach over a
period of several years and not people
would be infected you'd have what's
called herd immunity they heard
immunities meaningless until you in fact
over half the population and so you can
take you'll overload your medical system
so your case fatality rate instead of
being 1% will be like 3 4 percent and so
you know the idea it's very
irresponsible for somebody to suggest we
can have the best of both worlds what we
need is the extreme shutdown to so that
in six to ten weeks if things go well
then you can start opening back up so
just putting the math together from what
you just said bill to get to herd
immunity you needed more than half the
people in the country to basically get
the bug so in the case of the US for
example that'd be 150 million people
there abouts you said that there could
be that the fatality rate in that
scenario you're talking about four to
five million people and that in that
potential fatalities I mean it's like
like it thought that's just a horrifying
scenario that no one should be
contemplating even one percent of their
population getting sick they will treat
whoever goes for this ignore the disease
strategy they will treat them as a
pariah state so no none of their people
will go in and none of your people will
go into that and so briefly a few
countries in Europe that haven't really
looked at this hard considered okay
should be we be the ones who kind of go
about business as usual it is tempting
because if if you got there early South
Korea did not have to do the extreme
shutdown because they did such a good
job on testing and you know
that's why testing and containment mean
to me that the government's not
allocating the testing to to where it's
needed you know and maybe that'll have
to happen at the state level because
it's it's not having at the federal
level but there is there is no middle
course on this thing it is sad that the
shutdown will be harder for poor
countries than it is for richer
countries
so let's come into that in a minute but
just it's the one exception I've had the
case-mate for is Japan that Japan has
not contained it and quite in the same
way that South Korea did but has allowed
people to work it's try to make extreme
measures for protecting the most elderly
population but they've they've tried to
sort of let they try to find a middle of
scenario haven't they well if you act
when you have you know hundreds of cases
you may be able to contain it by doing
great testing and great contact tracing
and restricting foreigners coming in
without as much damage to our economy
the US has passed this opportunity to
control without shutdown so that the
worst case of what was happening in
Wuhan in the beginning or in northern
Italy you know the last few weeks that
we avoid that but we we did not have
fast enough to have a an ability to
avoid the shutdown but then what I don't
understand in the case of the US for
example is that if if even if we're
successful in bending the curve and
reducing the number of new cases from a
period of extreme shutdown as it were no
immunity has been built up let's say
that there's still no vaccine surely
when you lift restrictions and people
start going back to what the whole thing
just blows up again
the experience that we're seeing in
China and in South Korea is that there
are not these people are asymptomatic
that are causing lots of infections and
that's a parameter that if you build the
model you have to put in if there's an
imperial model that people talk about a
lot which shows that reopening is very
hard to do but it the results of that
model are not matching what we see in
China and so very likely there aren't as
many of these infecting asymptomatic s'
and that's what you have to be pragmatic
there's a lot we don't know for example
seasonality may help us in the northern
hemisphere the force of infection will
respiratory viruses to some degree they
all are our seasonal we don't know how
seasonal this one is but you know
there's a reasonable chance that the
force of infection will be going down
and it's you're testing that always is
telling you oh my gosh do I have to shut
down more or can I start to open up so
particularly right as you open up that
testing and contact tracing is is saying
to you and I'm you know you can say I'm
on the more optimistic side that it will
be possible to do what China's doing
where you know they are starting to go
back to normal and help me understand
what happened that it's it seems kind of
miraculous to me because they this virus
was exploding yes in Wuhan but but
people moved from there to many other
parts of China how is it possible that
that the combination of the shut down in
Wuhan and measures elsewhere seem to
have got to the point where there are
literally no new cases happening I mean
to me that implies that literally the
virus is not circulating at all between
humans in China how on you know there's
a few tourists coming in who they deal
with but I mean how on earth like is
that is that literally your
interpretation of what happened that
it's no longer second is take a
spreadsheet and take a number like for
one person affects four people and say
the cycle you knows every ten
days go through you know eight of those
cycles and you're getting a big number
you know start with ten thousand and
then you know that increase if you take
the number point four instead that is
the average case in facts point four
people which then look at what happens
to that number as you go out it drops to
zero and so things that are exponential
are very very dramatic when they're
above one they are growing rapidly when
they're below one they're shrinking
rapidly and so the isolation in China
drove that reproductive number to well
below zero and to locally below one
below one sorry and it's a you know
that's that quarantine that's you know
quarantine comes from forty days which
is what they thought would help for
black black plague that is our primary
technique thank God we have testing if
we use it properly we are you know doing
therapeutics which will help with the
death rate but in terms of the keeping
infections will one percent of the
population it's it's really all depends
just on the two things isolation and
testing so it's a question for my
twitter feed this morning for you bill
but if you were president for a month in
the US what would be the the top two or
three things you would do well the clear
message that we have no choice to
maintain this isolation and that's going
to keep going for a period of time you
know probably in the Chinese case it was
like six weeks so we have to prepare
ourselves for that and do it very well
and then use the testing and every week
talk about what's going on with that if
you're doing isolation well within about
twenty days you'll see those numbers
really change you know instead of this
you'll see this and
is a sign that you're on your way it now
you have to stay to get those more
generations that are you know point four
infections per previous infection you
have to maintain it for a number of
weeks there and you know so this is not
gonna be easy we need a clear message
about that it is really tragic that the
economic effects of this are very
dramatic I mean nothing like this has
ever happened to the economy in our our
lifetimes but money you know bringing
the economy back on doing money that's
more of a reversible thing than bringing
people back to life and so we're going
to take the pain in the economic
dimension huge pain in order to minimize
the pain in the disease and death
dimension Whitney we have a lot of other
questions coming in one of the ones that
we've been seeing is this a question
about what tools are available for
countries that maybe don't have the
luxury of being able to social distance
don't have great health systems in place
how should they be handling this virus
yeah I would say that if the rich
countries really do their job well by
the summer they'll be like China is are
some of the other countries that
responded early but in the developing
countries particularly in the southern
hemisphere this seasonality is is large
the as you say the ability to isolate
you know when you go out to get your
food every day you know you have to earn
your wage when you live in a Aslam where
you're very near by each other it's very
hard to do as you move down the income
ladder then it is for a country like
like the United States and so we should
all you know accelerate the vaccine
which eventually will come and you know
people are being responsible to say that
you know that's going to take 18 months
and there's a lot of those being pursued
you know I'm talking
with South Berkeley who you're gonna
have later this week who can talk a lot
about the vaccine front because he's
definitely at the center of that at
being the head of of Gavi we do need to
get really cheap testing out to these
countries and we need to get
therapeutics so you don't need to put 5%
of people on respirators because even if
they had the equipment they don't have
the personnel they just don't have the
beds the capacity and so the only good
news is that the rich countries have
this and so they will be learning about
testing therapeutics and funding the
vaccines for the entire world to try and
minimize the the damage in developing
countries great I'll be back later with
more questions yeah bill you mentioned
therapeutics there what is looking
promising is anything looking promising
yeah so there's quite a range of things
going on there's a few that get
mentioned blot REM sabadie r
hydrochloric Anisa through myosin and
the date is still a bit confusing but
there's some positive data on those rm7
here is a five-day IV infusion and
actually kind of hard to manufacturer so
people are looking at how that can be
improved the hydrochloric in looks like
it works somewhat if you get an early
there are a huge list of compounds
including antibodies antiviral drugs and
so the Gates Foundation and Wellcome
Trust would support from MasterCard now
others created this therapeutics
accelerator to really triage out you
have hundreds of people showing up and
saying trying this try that so we look
at lab assays animal models and so we
understand which things should be
prioritized for these very quick human
trials that need to be done all over the
world and so the coordination on that is
very complex globally but I think you
know out of the top 20 or
so candidates probably three or four of
them will work out you know at different
stages of the disease to reduce the
respiratory distress
I heard you mention that one possibility
might be treatments from the serum the
blood serum of people who had had the
disease and recovered so I guess they're
carrying antibodies talk a bit about
that about how that could work and what
it would take to accelerate that yeah
this has always been discussed is how
could you pull that off so people who
are recovered it appears have really
effective antibodies in their blood so
you could go transfuse them and only
take out the the white cells the immune
cells and then the question is okay how
many patients worth of material could
you get you know if you have that
recovered person come in say once a week
do you get enough for two people or five
people then logistically you have to
take that and get it to where that need
is and so it's it's fairly complicated
if you know compared to a drug that we
can make and high-volume
you know the cost of taking it out and
putting it back in probably doesn't
scale as well but there's what there is
work being done on this it you know we
actually started with the bowl
unfortunately it got done before it was
needed so that is being pursued and
it'll work to some degree but it'll be
hard to to scale the numbers so it's
almost like when you when you talk about
the need to accelerate testing the
immediate need is for testing for the
virus but is it possible that in a few
months time that there's been me this
growing need to test for these
antibodies and people - I need to see if
someone had the disease and recovered
maybe they didn't even know they they
had it because you could picture this
growing worldwide force of heroes let's
call them heroes who've been through
this experience and have a lot to offer
the world maybe maybe they can offer you
know like blood blood donations here
nation but also other tasks like if
you've got overwhelmed health care
systems presumably there are kind of
community health worker type tasks that
people could be trained to do to relieve
the pressure that if we knew that they
were as effectively immune yes until we
came up with the South swab and showed
FDA that that's equivalent we were
thinking the people who might be able to
man those kiosks would be the recovered
patients now we don't want to have a lot
of recovered people you know to be clear
we're trying through the shutdown in the
United States to not get to 1% of the
population infected we're well below
that today but with exponentiation you
know you could get past that about 3
million i'm i believe we will be able to
avoid that with the having this economic
pain eventually what we'll have to have
a certificates of who's a recovered
person who's a vaccinated person because
you don't want people moving around the
world where you'll have some countries
that won't have it under control sadly
you don't want to completely block off
the ability for those you know people to
go there and come back and move around
bill is your foundation helping to
accelerate the manufacture of these self
tests what are the prospects for really
seeing scale and some of this testing
soon not just a new s but that but
globally yeah our foundation we'd been
funding a thing called the flu study to
really understand how respiratory
viruses spread it's amazing how little
was understood about how important
schools are different age groups
different types of interaction and that
gave us an experience in fact that flu
study actually was the first time corona
virus was found in the community because
the government was still saying you only
test people who come from china but we
ran into people who had chronic virus
who weren't hadn't been travelers so you
know that was like an early warning sign
even though the regulation said you
weren't supposed to even look at that so
yeah the foundation is
working with all the private sector
people the Diagnostics people on this
testing piece the now that we can do the
self swab those swabs are very easy to
manufacture the one where you had to
jamming into the throat deep turbinate
that was getting into short supply so
the swab you know should not be limiting
neither should the the various chemicals
that help run the the PCR machine so we
we should be able to get to a South
Korea type prioritized testing thing
within within a few weeks how important
is it that the world's nations
collaborate right now I mean it's you
know it's like you know here's this
common enemy facing humanity it does not
know that it just crossed a border it
does not know what race people are what
religion they are it just knows here's a
human I've got I've got I've got a
manufacturing machine here that can make
me famous and and it goes to work ha
it's so terrifying to me to see signs of
doubt of countries starting to blame
each other or you know that the
xenophobia just seems so toxic how do
you how what's your take on this bill is
there anything do you see signs of
cooperation happening or are you also
worried about the sort of us versus
China kind of thing that seems to be
going on if we're not careful well I see
both I see that countries that are
recovered can help other countries and
that you know that's fantastic
if by the summer we've knocked this
thing down then great we can help other
countries there are vaccine projects all
over the world the nose should be
evaluated on a very neutral basis to
which one is the the best to help
humanity and make sure the manufacturing
capacity isn't just for rich countries
that had scaled up very low cost uh for
the entire world and that's the spirit
of Gavi is getting vaccines out to every
person so you see really good in the
science side and
data sharing side you see this great
cooperation going on unfortunately
whenever you have disease this sense of
other and foreign and no stay away from
me are you know that sort of pulling
inward is reinforced and we have to
avoid that you know ironically we have
to isolate physically while in terms of
looking at community groups that are
pooling resources to help make sure food
gets to everyone and helps your medical
care and that you know if older people
need to be moved out of common
facilities you help out with that and
you know people aren't suffering too
much from the psychology of isolation so
our generosity has to go out towards
others at the same time or less actually
physically in interacting with other
people I mean thinking about the
situation in many developing countries
I'm curious how you think of this I mean
you mentioned festival that seasonality
may help ie high temperatures is it
possible that that is so far protecting
pace to some extent places like India or
sub-saharan Africa and so forth in
india's northern hemisphere so southern
hemisphere is lots of Africa South
America Australia New Zealand Indonesia
and it is true either they're not the
either the force of infection is lower
there we're just not seeing it with
testing you know a few months from now
we'll understand the seasonality
question which would be good news for
the northern hemisphere and somewhat bad
news for the summit hemisphere now more
people live in the northern hemisphere
including you know India Pakistan and
that would buy us some time the time is
a big deal because all these tools get
so much better if you had to go into a
second season with it but yes sadly we
could see in the next few months is the
southern hemisphere is moving into it's
a fall and then winter we could see a
big increase there and and that is going
to be very difficult now they don't have
as many older people but they have lots
people who have four hiv-positive or how
about nutrition are various lung
challenges because of indoor smoke and
so the wild card is how well can the
developing countries deal with this I
mean if you're in a country where you
have the majority of your populations
making less than two or three dollars a
day can you even afford a strategy that
looks looks like basically shutting down
the economy I'm very worried that there
will be a massive number of deaths in
those poor countries because the health
systems just aren't you know the number
of respirators hospitals and of course
when you overload that system your
deaths are not just koba deaths but the
everyone else who's trying to access a
system that will be somewhat in chaos
including with health workers who are
getting sick okay we're getting near to
running out of time of this wouldn't it
maybe allows the question or two from
online sure so we have two from online
we're seeing thousands of questions
around these same lines one there's lots
of people who are really interested to
hear about the kind of work that you're
doing with your foundation as far as
distributing tests but also producing at
producing safety gear masks and that
sort of thing to help with this effort
for health workers yeah so the Gates
Foundation
you know we very early on gave out a
hundred million to help out with all the
pieces the testing piece the
therapeutics and the vaccines we are not
experts in making masks and ventilators
and gowns and it's great that other
people including some 3d printing and
open source things that is great
our focus you know like these self swab
thing it you know nobody had done that
before people thought it wouldn't work
we were quite sure it would work and so
that for the globe is a huge thing we
work a lot with both governments on
private sector so in some ways we're
kind of a bridge and you know so we've
been talking to the head of the
pharmaceutical companies and the testing
companies and specifically with the ones
doing vaccines including some of which
are these new
the vaccines are na vaccines that we've
been backing you know for quite some
time and sepi has been backing and so
our expertise are is in those medical
tools and really getting the best of the
private sector engaged there it's been a
little slow we can write checks you know
right away whereas the government
processes even in this situation you
know there's still this notion of
bidding and not really knowing who has
the unique capabilities of doing things
and you know so an organization that's
working on this all the time lots of new
vaccines can step in and and and be
helpful and it's really amazing when we
talk to private sector partners their
interest in helping out is has been
absolutely fantastic and you know so
that's where we're we have a unique role
that's great and I mean and the other
question that we're just seeing a ton of
before we wrap up here is is it's just
people are really interested in your
insight bill on whether you think we're
heading in the right direction do you
feel like our economy is heading in the
right place that humanity is heading in
the right place are we in a better
position now than you thought we were in
five years ago well the five years ago I
said that the pandemic is this
unaddressed very very scary thing and
that you know if we did the right things
we could be more prepared science is on
our side the the fact we can be ready
for the next epidemic it's very clear
how to do that and yes it will take tens
of billions but not hundreds or
trillions of dollars so it'll be tiny
compared to the economic cost I remember
when I did that presentation of 2015 I
put up a hey you know a big flu epidemic
could cost four trillion I thought wow
that's a big number do I really think
it's that big and I went and took the
murse I thought yeah well that that's
big this epidemic will cost that much to
the economy so in the short run we are
going to have more pain and more
difficulty
and people are going to have to step up
to help each other I'm still very much
an optimist you know whether its climate
change countries working together
biology taking the diseases malaria TB
you know even advances for what are more
ritual diseases like cancer the amount
of innovation the way we can connect up
and work together yes
I'm super positive about that you know I
love my work because I see progress on
all these diseases all the time now we
have to you know turn and and focus on
this you know sadly it may interrupt and
the polio situation might get worse a
little bit because of the distraction
here you know we're using a lot of the
great capacity that was built up for
those polio activities to try and help
the developing countries respond to this
very well and that that is appropriate
but you know the message for me although
it's very sober when we're dealing with
this epidemic
you know I'm I'm very positive that this
should draw us together we will get out
of this and then we will get ready for
the next epidemic that's that's exactly
what I was going to ask you fellas which
is a help where's your head do you think
we that we will get through this will
the leaders that matter listen to the
scientists will they will we make it
through did you believe that within a
few months time we're going to be
already looking back and saying we
dodged a pretty bad one there we can't
say for sure that even the rich
countries will be out of this in six to
ten weeks
I think that's likely but as we get the
testing data we'll get more of a sense
of that and people continuously be able
to see that but you know the rich
countries will got out of this the
developing countries will bear a
significant price but even they we will
get a vaccine and you know Gavi we'll
get that out to to everyone so you know
two to three years from now this thing
even on a global basis will essentially
be
/ with a gigantic price tag but now
we're gonna know okay next time we see a
pathogen we can make billions of tests
within two or three weeks we can figure
out which antiviral drugs work within
two or three weeks and get those killed
up and we can make a vaccine if we're
really ready probably in six months
using these new platforms probably the
RNA vaccine so specifically there are
innovations that are there that will get
financed you know I hope quite
generously coming out of this thing and
so three years from now we'll look back
and say you know that was awful there's
a lot of heroes but we've learned the
lesson and and the world as a whole
with its great science and desire to
help each other was able to try and
minimize what happened there and and and
you know avoid it happening again that
certainly the optimistic scenario that
I'm craving for myself that the world
kind of realizes one that there are
certain things that you just have to
unite on to that science really matters
and that side that it's a miracle that
science can understand this bug you know
make a vaccine in the sequencer to make
therapeutics understand how to model it
it's kind of miraculous to me so will we
learn now to that to pay attention to
scientists because if we do I I'm sure
that you feel this as well there's an
amazing analog right with climate it's
just a different timescale that the
scientists are out there saying there's
this huge enemy coming if we do nothing
it's going to take millions of lives
it's going to wreck our planet for God's
sake at politicians do something and the
politicians are going no need little
more GDP we need to win an election and
they're not acting mate I mean is that
do you see a scenario where this shocks
politicians to actually change their
thinking and their prioritization of
science that we're all at that asking
too much yeah it's interesting how much
of this distraction will delay the
urgent innovation agenda
that exists over in climate you know I
have freed up a lot of time to work on
climate I have to say you know for the
last few months that's now shifted and
until we get out of this crisis
Cobin will dominate and so some of the
climate stuff although it'll still go on
it won't get that same focus is we get
past this yes that I did innovation in
science and the world working together
that is totally common between these two
problems and so I don't think this has
to be a huge setback for climate so last
question there there are thousands of
people watching many of them living
alone some quote scared they're making
these people that who have this virus
and suffering symptoms are recovering by
the way if that's if that's you we'd
love to hear from you
we really would maybe have a
conversation with some of you have just
you know in a future one of these just
understanding the experience but bill
what can people do as individuals from
their own homes right now to try and
help well there's a lot of creativity
you know can you mentor kids who are
being forced into an online format where
the school systems really weren't ready
for that can you
organize some giving activity that gets
the you know the food banks to step up
where there's problems there these are
such unprecedent at times and it really
should draw out that that sense of you
know creativity Wow complying with the
isolation mandates well bill I really
want to thank you for spending this this
time with us and for the the financial
investment the time investment you've
really invested your life into trying to
solve these big problems and this is as
big as they get I have a hunch that your
voice is really gonna be needed in the
next few weeks thank you so much for
your for your time today this was this
was really wonderful hearing from you
thank you you know thanks Chris okay
well thanks everyone thanks for being
part of the tech community look after
yourselves to be smart about this you
know it's like get ahead of it if you're
in a part of the world where this thing
hasn't really hit listen to Bill Gates
get ahead of it to keep you know it just
if you possibly can
socially a distance not not physically
distance and socially connect that's
what the internet is for these days are
what the internet was built for we can
spread love we can spread ideas we can
spread relationship we can spread
thought without spreading a dangerous
bug so get ahead of it and let's figure
this out together it's been wonderful
spending time with you from Whitney and
for me and from the whole Ted team thank
you